look at that face look at that face you
know it's interesting to me mr. Trump
said that he heard mr. Bush very clearly
I think women all over this country
heard very clearly what mr. Trump said
through respect mr. Trump we have been
talking about illegal immigration for 25
years Democrats don't want this issue
solved mister even the marijuana that
kids are smoking today is not the same
as the marijuana that Jeb Bush smoked 40
years ago we do sorry Barbara
we have the highest incarceration rates
in the world two-thirds of the people in
our prisons are there for nonviolent
offenses mostly drug-related it's
clearly not working I dare Hillary
Clinton Barack Obama to watch these
tapes watch a fully formed fetus on the
table its heart beating its legs kicking
while someone says we have to keep it
alive to harvest its brain this is about
the character of our nation mrs. Clinton
is going to have to defend her track
record of lying about Benghazi of lying
about her emails lying about her servers
she does not have a track record of
accomplishment like mrs. Clinton I too
have traveled hundreds of thousands of
miles around the globe unlike mrs.
Clinton I know that flying is an
activity it is not an accomplishment
because you can't just wave your hands
and say the 14th amendment is going to
go away it will you ran up mountains of
debt as well as losses using other
people's money and you were forced to
file for bankruptcy not once I never saw
twice four times a record four times why
should we trust you this was a big lie
when you manage the finances of your
concern
he did